Here we are
in Sacramento, California,
at the state capital.
Not only a beautiful building,
but a place that welcomes me
with open arms.
This is where
I was given my day.
February 22 is Kevin Hart day.
This is where
it all happened at.
- Your day?
- My day. Breathe it in.
- Who told you to stop by?
- Everybody did,
'cause I came
and I wooed people.
Follow me,
and wipe your feet off
before you go inside.
- We outside still, why--
- Wipe your foot off!
- I was gonna wipe mine off.
- Act like you with Kevin Hart.
Look, I don't just say
that I'm a big deal
around these parts, guys.
I'll show you.
Read it.
That's a senator, okay?
Senator Hall, my friend.
- Kev, you know,
you ain't got to do this.
- No, I do.
I'm gonna introduce you.
I'm gonna introduce you,
just relax.
[knocks on door]
Senator!
Senator Hall.
Hizzo!
[knocks on door]
Senator.
Ah!
- Kev.
- Ah!
- What's up, bro?
- How can I help you, man?
- Boy, look at--how you help me?
Give me a hug.
- Man.
- What'd you eat, barbeque?
You smell like--
- What's going on?
What's going on, man?
- I wanted to introduce you
to my friends, man.
- Yeah.
- That's Harry right there.
I call him Bucket Low.
That's Joey right there.
Good friend of mine, man.
We do a lot of work together.
I want to show
these guys the ropes.
I want to show them your office.
Give me--give me--yeah--
Give me one second.
- Well, hold on.
Before you go, let me--
- Give me one second.
One second.
- Hey--
- Hey, security!
- Okay.
- Security!
Hey.
You all right in there?
You need your back up?
I'm here.
- No, he called security.
- That's why I'm making sure
he okay.
- No, no, no, no, no--
- Senator, you all right?
- I think he called them on you.
- On you.
- Well, he didn't call on me--
Hey, Hizzo!
I don't see why
he would have called--
- Whoa, we got to go.
- Hizzo, I'ma call your phone.
Come on. Let's just--
let's just go.
[hip-hop music]